when people are when people are also um
how do i say when they're when they're
noticed by god and touched by god
from a juvenile when my clothes had
holes in them
and my
salaam alaikum guys hope you guys are
welcome charlotte welcome back to my
channel today i was um
having some free time at home in the
lockdown
and i came across matt tyson's podcast i
didn't even know he actually had a
podcast
um and it caught my attention and i
thought let me listen to you and he had
um a guest over
acon um which i'm going to do another
video uh with
aikon and mike tyson basically in the
same podcast in another video soon
but something he said here which was i
would say
roughly what 10 seconds was
so profound so amazing
and i had to share it with you guys i'm
not going to hold you guys any longer
let's hear it for ourselves and this was
just deep man deep um and this will
change our life this this will this will
definitely change our life insurance
listen to what
mike tyson had to say in this podcast
here we go
when people are when people are also um
how do i say when they're when they're
noticed by god and touched by god
they're also they're noticed by the
devil too well
this listen to it again so we can put
that into perspective
when people are when people are also
um how do i say when they're when
they're noticed by god and touched by
god
they also they noticed by the devil too
when you get noticed by allah with your
effort
guess who else has got their eyes on you
it please and when he notices you here
is what happens
it's just interesting if the guard
noticed you he noticed you too
yeah now that now the battle begins that
is so true man
that'd be the toughest part because
sometimes you don't know you just think
there's just hard times hitting you
but believe me that what that fight is
that's the most that's the hardest one
especially when you're working for
something you can taste it you can feel
it you know you're right there and it's
always these temptations and
obstacles that just stand in the front
and you can easily go the same
success but in a whole other direction
if you just be misled by two seconds or
you lose faith for a second
or you can just stay on that path and
just make a legacy out of yourself in a
positive way
guys so why in a nutshell when allah
notices you in the context of when
you're putting that effort forward
when you're trying to get closer to
allah when you're trying to say no to
the bad friends
to the girls and the boys and the cars
and the drugs and the money and whatever
it may be
and you want to do a u-turn in your life
a u-turn that i
personally made and many people made you
know
um and how hard it is and we know how
hard it is i've been through it and a
lot of you guys may have as well
and there are there are those who are
listening to this that
want to the moment you are noticed by
allah
meaning allah subhanahu was all seeing
of course you know
but for allah to see the effort that
you're putting forward
yeah and you're taking that step towards
him at the prophet sallallahu sallam
said
if you come to allah walking will come
to you running yeah
and we're not saying literally yeah so
the thing is here brothers and sisters
is the following
when you put that effort forward and
allah notices and says yes
that is one of my chosen servants yeah
and we know from another verse in the
quran where allah tells us
that his chosen servants those who
wrong themselves and those who come to
allah
mediocrity they're trying their best
they do they do they do what's in the
father etc and those who
outpace others notice how allah even
talks about that one of the
chosen people are who the ones who even
wronged themselves
the sinners yeah because they are
sinners but
they choose to come to crosstalk
um and subhanallah this is amazing now
allah
sees the potential in you yeah in the
context of he sees you're making the
effort like i said before
and allah says
[Music]
and by the salt and the one who made it
well allah
then inspired it with instincts of evil
and piety
listen carefully success is really
attained by him who purifies it
and failure is really suffered by him
who pollutes it
imagine you have two glasses in front of
you one is polluted
well let's talk about they're both half
filled one's got dirty water in it
or let's just i'll give it a dirty water
and one's got pure water in it
a lot of the planets are saying and by
the one and by the soul
and the one who made it well and then
inspired it with
instincts of evil and piety so see the
evil as the dirty water and piety
with the pure water success is really
attained by him who purifies it
how do you purify a dirty water you add
water in it pure water in it until the
dirt is gone
and failure is really suffered by him
who pollutes it
so the dirty water that you have if you
fill it
if you fill it with more dirt you're
gonna get
the end result's gonna be what bigger
dirt
and brothers and sisters this is why
it's so important if you listen to the
economic ties and what might
said was amazing allah notices you so
the moment you see the struggles
the tests are getting harder and harder
and harder it doesn't make sense
this is this shows you that you are on
the right path
and shaytan is not going to busy himself
with those who go clubbing drugs
committing xena drinking alcohol and
doing all kinds of evil deeds
he hasn't got time for them why because
they're already there
and allah says in the quran chapter 43
verse 36
and whoever turns away blinds himself
from the remembrance of the most
beneficial allah
is
an intimate companion to him so brothers
and sisters
as you can see that subhan allah he
believes the shaytan will come
and he will busy herself busy himself
with you
and isn't it beautiful that if you are
in the struggle and the hardship that
you're going to know
that others notice the struggles you're
doing and is bringing you closer to him
do not see certain calamities in your
life as oh my god allah hates me no no
no if that was the case allah hates all
the prophets then
the struggles they went through it's by
these
struggles that we turn close to allah
there are many people that i've seen
that have turned to the remnants of
allah by calamities that's hit them
and that's what allah says it will send
a smaller calamity
to divert a bigger calamity in the
hereafter so if
anything that brings you closer to allah
is nothing but a blessing
and we're going to finish off my tyson's
word beautifully said
the moment god notices you
know that you've got somebody else who's
noticed as well
and that is shaytan and he's gonna try
his best like he said to allah i'm gonna
come from the back then the front and
the left and the right
brothers and sisters keep firm to the
rope of allah
and unto the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
may allah make us amongst those who are
sincere amongst those who strive in the
course of allah
and make us among those who have a good
ending
and may allah grant his journal thank
you for watching this video more videos
will be coming
as i watch more clips of my titus new
podcast
and with acorn uh soon it will be coming
in a couple of
this time until next time goodbye mom
and sisters don't forget to check back
with the job channel
and nishan's and the rest
you